you used to call me on my cell phone
late night when you need my love the
certified lover boy is living up to his
name in a unique way jewelry designer
Alex Moss shared a video on Instagram of
his newest piece for Drake called
previous engagements
bordering The Impossible an expedition
spanning 14 months every Diamond hand
selected inspected to only suit
Perfection the stunning bling is made up
of 42 diamonds totaling
351.38 carats mounted in an 18 karat
white gold according to the video's
caption the necklace represents all the
times he thought about it but never did
it the announcement of the previous
engagements collaboration comes fresh
off a recent Saturday Night Live skit
where Drake's exes form a Union against
him have you ever dated the rapper Drake
have you ever met Drake at a party
talked on Instagram or even made flirty
eye contact with him at a restaurant has
Drake then referenced you your
relationship or the potential thereof in
a song if the answer is yes you are not
alone while it's not certain who
represents each of the 42 Diamonds the
rapper has been rumored to be linked to
Rihanna scissor Tyra Banks and Julia Fox